yeah I have no idea yeah bro probably my
least favorite type of puzzle no I would
go with Perpetual if I if I I was
playing in BL bullet yes fast yeah no
that's not the solution of course I've
seen it but like I I don't it's so
annoying because I don't want to uh I'm
going to guess that it's Bishop takes E6
nope nope okay Knight F6 or something
Knight F6 baby okay he got the Right
Moves no no way no way no way no no way
yeah so Knight F6 Bishop takes C3 E3 F3
and then after King takes G6 oh there's
Queen to F5 and Bishop H7 there it is
Queen F5 W heat he got it let's go fyro
let's go baby ah queen of five come on
there it is yeah nice very nice very
nice that's a pretty one a pretty one
very
hard I know okay well go ahead
definitely tell the camera we got I just
say queen of five check oh yeah queen of
five check in the end yep